مساء الخير اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه
التغطيه المباشره على شاشه العربيه ننتقل
مباشره الى الامم المتحده ومناقشات حول
ملف السودان
الان مع وزير الشؤون المجتمعيه الذي يحاول
ان يسهل عملنا واخيرا وليس اخيرا
انتشار السريعه مستعده لنشرها
والعمل جارب ما تحدث هو امل ان تمنح سلطات
الضوء الاخضر للاطراف الانسانيين لان
هنالك رغبه كثيره ولكن ادوات قليله
وجلب عدد اكبر من الموظفين
سيساعد العظماني فرقنا في دارفور وكاسلا
وقدره
ومدني لديهم ما يكفي من
العدد الاتصالات لاتمام عملهم كما ان
عمليه الحشد الجاريه وما علينا ان نستعد
له الان هو زياده استجابتنا ونضمن ان
الحوار
حول القانون الدولي ليس فقط عليا بل حتى
في الجذور لكي فرقنا ونضمن
ان قيادتي القوات الدعم السريع وجيستاني
ملتزمه بذلك كما تعرفون فهذا الثقل من
اضرار المدنيه ويضمن
بيئه الشامل لاي مفاوضات التي تبدا بدلا
من مدينه مدمره ومستشفيات مدمره
نحن بحاجه اليه هو المحافظه عليها لكي
تكون الظروف مئاتيه لاتمام الحوار بين
الاطراف
عقيل كلمه لفرد
وبعد ذلك السيده لوكا
والدكتور اني منظمه الصحه العالميه
شكرا جزيلا انا اتفق مع زميلي باتريك
الذي
عبر عن موقفنا
نحن قلقنا جدا بعد 11 يوما من القتال الى
الان لم يكن هناك يتطور في الاوضاع
نو اي بوادر لوقف القتال ما يزيد من
التحديات الانسانيه المشكله الاساسيه هي
العجز في مواد الغذائي والمائي والطعم
والكهربائي والمواد الطبيه
الاسعار ايضا ارتفعت بشكل كبير من ضمنها
اسعار المواد الطبيه والنقل والغذاء
كما ذكر باتشيك نحن على اتصال بالزملاء
بالهلال الاحمر المصري
وجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الاخرى لدعم
المحتاجين سواء هؤلاء الخارجين من البلاد
والعائدين الى اوطانهم
وهذا يشمل حتى الفرق الدوليه المتواجده في
السودان
في الخرطوم العائلات
عالقه في منازلهم
وبانتظار الاجلاء
ونحن او هم دائما يطالبون بالغذاء والمياه
التي بدات تنفد
كما عملنا مع الزملاء هنا في الهلال
الاحمر السوداني
والى جانب الصليب الاحمر الدولي لضمان
المطوعين وفرق الهلال الاحمر
قادرون على استمرار بالعمل واغلب
المتطوعين يعملون في حوالي 60 مستشفى في
الخرطوم
الى جانب الكوادر الطبيه كما تمكنا من
تزويدهم ببعض الادويه وللاسف فان مخزوننا
فيما قاري الهلال الاحمر السوداني سرقه
قبل بضعه ايام
لقد وافقنا على 475
الف اللي حشدي المستوعين الموظفين وكذلك
توفير المزيد من موارد الانسانيه
وسك ذلك لحجز تطوع حول البلاد
نحن مستمرين بمراقبته الاوضاع
وحشت الموارد الانسانيه الضروريه لنضمن
استمرار عمل الهلال الاحمر السوداني
كما تعرفون بانهم متواجدون في محافظه 18
بالكامل وهنالك متطوعين في مجالات الصحه
وتوفير المياه
والدعم المجتمعي وكلهم مستعدون لتقديم
الدعم والخدمات الانسانيه
عندما تفتح او البوابات الانسانيه شكرا
جزيلا
اشكرك على احاطتك
اوكي
في العيد كانت لدينا الفرق على الحدود
بعد احداثها الخرطوم
الثلاثاء
بتوجيه من زملائنا
اشهدنا وصول الاف اللاجئين من غير بي
دارفور
ومن قريه
محدده
الصوت غير واضح هو افضل بقليل من قبل ولكن
الصوت غير واضح
حتى وان كان الصوت غير واضح تماما
كما كنت اقول
بين كنت هناك يوم الثلاثاء بعد وصولي
اول مجموعه من عدتي الاف من اللاجئين
وسلطات المحليه تحدثت عن 11 الى 12 الف
لاجئ عبر الحدود من
وقريه محدده انا كنت هناك
ورايت عائلات باكمله العديد من النساء
والاطفال
وكل عائله
كانت تختبر تحت شجره لتحميل نفسها من
الشمس كنا هناك
وتعرفنا على احتياجات
الاساسيه والماء
غير متوافر واللاج جدا من الحدود
واخذوا المياه من الوادي وهذا امر خطير
جدا على الحدود وكما ان الغذاء هو رعايه
الصحيه
والمواد غير الغذائيه الاساسيه
النوم
متوفره الى الشرقي البلاد
فالاستجابه التي قدمناها في العيد كانت
مقيده قليلا لاننا كنا بحاجه لتحرك
باستمرار اما اليوم بينما اتحدث فهل نقوم
بعملياته التسجيل
ما يتم التسجيل الاشخاص سنقوم بالتوزيع
المنتجات الغذائيه وبعد ذلك سنبدا بالمواد
غير الغذائيه
والى جانب خطط للسجل مباشره لتوفير المياه
ورعايه الصحيه
وبمساعده المنظمات غير اللاحكوميه فنحن
نقدم الخططه لاعاده استقرار اللاجئين
منهم في المخيمات الى مواقع جديده سبق وان
حددناها مع السلطات نحن نتحدث عن حوالي 12
الفا
في هذه المحافظه
ولدينا زملاء
ذهبوا الى محافظه اخرى
حيث افادوا لنا عن وصول اربعه الاف لاجئ
اضافي
والاشخاص مستمرون عبور الحدود
واذا ما استمر فاطلق النار فسيكون هناك
عدد اكبر اشخاص من يعبرون الحدود فنحن
الان
نعمل مع حوالي 20 الف علاج
واليونس كما تعرفون
والى جانب التنسيق نحن نحشد غير غذائيه
سبق وان الم التقاها مثل المواد اللي خمسه
الاف شخص
وعدد من اليونيسف
وسنزود حوالي 30 الف اضافيه
الف شخص
نحن نتسابق الزمن
هنالك اشخاص اصحاب احتياجات ماسه بالقرب
للحدود كما يجب ان نصل الى الاشخاص الذين
يعبرون الحدود في مناطق بعيده
ولكن الى الان نحن نعمل مع 20 الف لاجئ
ونخطط لما يصل الى 100 الف لاجئ كاس
الحالات
[موسيقى]
نعتذر عن مشكله الصوت ورجعت الصوت
معنا الان وهي ممثله منظمه الصحه العالميه
من السودان
واعطيك الكلمه الدكتور انيمه
السودان
[موسيقى]
وجئنا لهنا من الخرطوم وكلنا بامان اود ان
ابدا
[موسيقى]
بتقديمي على التحيه للجهود عمال الصحافي
السودان وكذلك الفريق الوطني لمضم الصحه
العالميه الذين بحياتهم لانقاذ اكبر عدد
من الارواح في السودان في هذا الوضع
المعقد جدا اذا سمحتم لي
ساعطيكم منظوري الخاص وتجربتي
وربما يعطيكم ذلك فكره جيده انا لا اوضاع
هنا
وعائلتهم
كنا عالقين في مجمع وطلب من الانتقال الى
منطقه اخرى ليست ببعيده
عاده بين 15 لعشرين دقيقه غادرنا المجمع
برفقه الجيش
وبعد اقل 600 متر
اوقفت نقاط التفتيش لقوات الدعم السريع
وطلبوا منا
مغادره المركبات
واجرى تحقيقات معنا لحوالي عشرين دقيقه ثم
سمحوا لنا بالذهاب
الى مكاتب اليونيسف
فاقول لكم خلال 600 متر
هنالك
منطقه التي تسيطر عليهما مجموعه ثانيه
مختلفتان
وبين 500 الى 600 متر
شهاده جثث على الشوارع في اعداد الضحايا
الحيه التي
تستلمها
مركز الطوارئ
من
وتمثل 25% فقط
الاعداد الصوت غير واضح
ساعطيكم الارقام ولكنني شاهد عيان شاهدت
جثتين في الشارع بينما كنا ننتقل من
المجمع
اعداد الضحايا
في البوشات الخمسه وعشرين هي اربعه الاف
وخمسه وسبعين اصابه
و459 حاله الوفاه ولكن كما قلت فهذه
اقل بكثير من الاعداد الحقيقيه
والرقم الحقيقي اعلى بكثير من هذا
فالى الان
فقط 25% من المنشات التي نستطيع ان نقول
بانها تعمل بطاقتها الكامله
وهنا لكم
اغلقت بسبب الهجمات ومسائل امنيه
او انتقالهم الى قواعد عسكريه
واخطر ما يمكن يكون المراه في هو اذا ما
كانت في الشوارع في السودان
مع
عدم قدرته وصول المصابين الى المستشفيات
ولكن
هنالك اتصل قدر الامكان
وبعض الزملاء السودانيين
بعمليات فيها مجازفه كبيره جدا
وعلاوه على اعداد الضحايا
تلقيت مكالمه يوم امس
من رئيس مركز الصحه المحلي وتسيطر عليها
موحده من الاطراف المقاتله وقاموا بطرد
كافه الفنينه من مختبرات
والان هي تحت سيطره الكامله لواحده من
الاطراف المقاتله واصبح القاعده عسكريه
وهذا خطر للغايه
هنالك
عينات كثيره لامراض خطيره جدا فهنالك خطر
بعلوجي كبير جدا مرتبط
بسطرتهم على مركز
الصحه المحلي في الخرطوم من قبل احد الطرف
المتقاتلتين تحدثت عن الضحايا ولكن صدمات
النفسيه والصحه النفسيه في قتل الاهميه
وعلينا الا ننسى
المخاطر الصحيه العامه المرتبطه بهذا
القتال
لانهم مع عدم وجود المياه او الكهرباء
فبلا شك هنالك مخاطره كبيره الانتشاري
الكوليرا والخرطوم نفسها
سبق وان عانت او شهدت
اول شي لمرضى
جدا في كافه محافظات السودان
وهنالك الانتشار الاوبئه في عده منعطى
فالصحه العامه
[موسيقى]
وفي خطر كبير جدا من التفشيح هذه الاوبئه
فاتوقعاتي وللاسف
حواء انك البعض سيموت من التفشي الاوبئه
اذا ما استمر هذا القتال لفتره طويله وكل
اعداد اكبر بكثير
[موسيقى]
فالاولويه الان
هي يقوم الاطراف الادولين والقوى
الاقليميه ان يستمر بالضغط على اطراف
المقاتله
التوصل الى وقفه اطلاق النار كامل والا
فما نستطيع انكم خاصه في الخرطوم على
اوضاع الحاليه محدود جدا
الزملاء من وزاره الصحه من الصحه العالميه
اجازه بحياتهم
للتقديم دعم قليل جدا ولكنه يبدلون كل ما
في وسعهم
الاكبر هو حول زملائنا المحالين يعيشون في
الخرطوم
هنالك قرار
لنقلهم بشكل طوعي ولكن هذا فيه تحديات
كبير لاني شهدت بنفسي
حاله الانتقال من الساخنه من الخرطوم
وكانت صعبه للغايه وانا كنت محظوظا
للوصول الى هذه المنطقه ولكن تخوفي الان
هو على زملاء
السودانيين
العالقين في المناطق الساخنه
شكرا جزيلا دكتور نيما للاسف صوتك غير
واضح
همم سوري
اه اوكي
الاعداد
الجديده
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
اربعه عشر هجمه على منشات الصحيه العنف
ثماني وفيات واصابتين هجمات على مركز
الرعايه الصحيه يا جماعه تتوقف واحدث
الارقام ايش ذكرها الدكتور
هي 4000 و72 اصابه
و459 حاله وفاه للاسف
ولكنك كما ذكر الدكتور نيما
فهذه الارقام فيها بلا شك اقل بكثير مقام
الحقيقيه سنتوقف هنا واشكروا جميعكم
اشكركم جميعا على صدركم سمعنا تسعه
متحدثين على السودان هناك عدد اكبر من
الاسئله لمنقشتها سافسح المجال للاسئله
وسابدا من المتواجدين في القاعه
[موسيقى]
عن
ولكن
تتوقعون
حاربهم او
بس
لو اعطيتهم انا بعض التفاصيل
اذاعه الصوت
ويبدون هناك مختبر وطني تملا سيلا عليه لم
نفهم تمام مع هذا المختبر
لو اوضحت لنا
ما الذي حصل واخيرا كانت هنالك المزيد من
التفاصيل حول
العمال الذين تم اجلاهم العاملين في مجال
الانسانيه
هو ربما الدكتور انيمه سيردو بعدك
[موسيقى]
ليس لدينا عدد بالكامل الذين التقديرات
سمعنا عن التشاد وساعطيه الكلمه
الاعداد
ولم نشهده وصولي اي مهاجر الى بقيه الدول
الاخرى
[موسيقى]
سنطلعكم حلمه تريدون معلومات مع الطور
الاوضاع
وربما نحصل على معلومات اضافيه في الوقت
القريب
في جنوب السودان الارقام التي خططنا لها
للسيناريو المحتمل
هي 125 الف عائد من اللاجئين الجنوب
السوداني الى جنوب السوداني
45,000 لاجئ
ونعتقد بان العائدين او العوده تحصل فقد
مبكر واغلبها من الخرطوم
وتدفقات اللاجئين على الاكثر ستكون بعد
ذلك والسينار الارجحها هو الوضع الذي يكون
فيه
تقوم بها احد الطرفين المتقاتلين الذي
يسيطر على الخرطوم
واحتمت للعوده الى دارفور ومناطق اخرى من
السودان
العديده من الزملاء من جنوب السودان
لعائلاتهم في الخرطوم
وهنالك حركه كبيره للاشخاص الخارجين من
الخرطوم
ذهاب الى مصر
هنالك حركه كبيره في هذا الاتجاه
الدكتور نيما قال له اعطيتنا بعض التفاصيل
حول المختبر
لو اقتربت من الميكروفون
المشكله هي رجعت الاتصال
هو مختبر الرعايه الصحيه المركزي وهو
المختبر الرئيسي
وهنالك مخاطر عاليه جدا
بيولوجيه لان
الذين لعب كثيرا
الحصبه والكوليرا والاوبيا الاخرى
الفائده ما طفيت الكهرباء وعدم وجودي فني
مختص الي يهتمام بها فان المخاطر
البيولوجيه عاليه جدا في الخرطوم
بسبب الاستيلاء على هذا المختبر من قبل
احد الطرفين المتقاتلين
ولا داعي لذكر من هو هذا الطرف
ومعلوم من هو الطرف المسيطر
اعمل ان تكون الاجابه واضحه الان
كما اود ان اذكر انه خلال عمليه اجلاء
القصيره
شاهدت مستشفيعين
احدها مستشفى الشرطه
والاخرى مستشفى خاصه
وكلاهما كانت تستقبل عنها الاصابات خلال
اول يومين من
النزاع وهذه
مجرد مثال عامه شاهدته بنفسي
كشاهد عيان
فيما يخصه الاخيره لا اعتقنا دينا الاعداد
لكلمه
الاجابه
اخر احصائياتها خمسه
هذه التي نعرفها
شكرا جزيلا لنعد الى السؤال التالي
سودانية حول الاوضاع في السودان هناك حتى
الان تسعه متحدثين من ضمنهم باتريك يوسف
المديره الاقليمي لافريقيا لدى اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر الذي ناشد الاطراف
للسماح لموظفهم واعضاء الصليب الاحمر في
السودان بالقيام باعمالهم الانسانيه تجاه
المتضررين والمصابين وايضا من المتحدثين
قال كان ممثل منظمه الصحه العالميه في
السودان الذي ذكر بان عدد الوفيات وعدد
الاصابات اكثر بكثير مما هو معلن وذكر
ايضا ان خلال تنقله في الشوارع للنقطه
التي يتواجد فيها هو راى جثتين على الطريق
حتى الان اذا
احاطه من عده منظمات دوليه مشاهدينا حول
الاوضاع في السودان
والتغطيه مستمره على شاشه العربيه
ومنصاتها على شبكات التواصل للازمه
السودانيه المستمره في يومها الحادي عشر
الهدنه المعلنه منذ ليله الاثنين الى
الثلاثاء ولمده اثنتين وسبعين ساعه تعرضت
للخرق وسط استمرار التهم بين طرفي النزاع
قوات الدعم السريع كانت السباقه لتهام
الجيش بخرق الهدنه وتنفيذ طلعات جويه فوق
الخرطوم الرد على الاتهام جاء على لساني
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه التي ادانت ما
اسمته بنهج الدعم السريع في استهداف
السفراء والدبلوماسيين كما اكدت على
التزام الدوله بالهدنه وحرصها على حمايه
المدنيين الوضع على الارض اذا لا يزالها
الشن رغم المحاولات الدوليه لراس السطح
[موسيقى]
تتفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه وتزداد سوءا في
السودان حيث نفدت مواد غذائيه اساسيه من
متاجر العاصمه الخرطوم في ظل الاشتباكات
التي عمت مدن سودانيه اخرى بعد 11 يوما
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في وقت
ارتفعت اسعار المواد المتوفره على قلتها
وفق شهود عيان ورغم توقف معظم محطات
الوقود عن العمل في مدينه ام درمان لازال
الطوابير السيارات تطول وتطول
40 دقيقه بين اربعين الى 60 دقيقه
في هذا السياق توقفت شركه مرسي الدنماركيه
اكبر ناقله بحريه للحاويات توقفت عن اخذ
اي حجوزات جديده للبضائع في السودان بسبب
الاشتباكات ووفق البيان فان شركه الشحن
البحريه العملاقه تتابع التطورات في
السودان عن كثب وبناء عليه علقت استلام اي
بضائع من السودان ريثما يتحسن الوضع ويعود
للاستقرار الى سلسله التوريد في البلاد
معنا من معبر ارقين على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان اهلا
بك معنا احمد انقل لنا الصوره لديك
نعم اهلا بك فاطمه بالفعل يعني استمرار
لتدفق الحافلات على هذا المعبر منذ اكثر
من يومين هناك يعني اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
الى خمسه الاف لا توجد حتى الان احصائيات
رسميه للكثير من المواطنين هذه النسب
اغلبها من المصريين وايضا من السودانيين
والكثير من الجليات التي لفت نظري بان
اغلبها ينتمون الى دول اوروبيه مثل جورجيا
واوكرانيا والذي كان فيه استقبالهم ممثلون
ومبعوثون وايضا بعض السفراء الذين اشرفوا
على عمليه نقلهم واستقبالهم من هذا المنفذ
فيما يتعلق
من سجلنا معهم يعني اغلبهم يبدو عليهم
علامات الارهاق تحدثوا باقتضاض شديد جدا
حول هول ما راوه في السودان الرحله
الطويله يعني 900 كم من كانوا في الخرطوم
للوصول الى هذا المنفذ ومن ثم ايضا
الارهاق المتوقع للوصول الى اكبر مركز هنا
في بعد هذا المنفذ في مدينه اسوان بعد
حوالي خمس ساعات من المرور سواء كانت
سيارات او حافلات اغلب من تحدثنا معهم من
ابناء السودان اعلنوا بانهم سيتوجهون
مبدئيا الى اسوان هذه المدينه التي تشهد
جاليه سودانيه كبيره هناك الكثير من
الاقارب والاصدقاء الذين سيتوجهون اليهم
ربما لمراقبه ورصد تطورات المشهد السياسي
والميداني والامن في السودان قبل اتخاذ
القرار سواء المكوث هنا لفتره او التوجه
للقاهره او العوده مره اخرى لان كثير ممن
تحدثنا معهم اكدوا بانهم جاءوا بما عليهم
من ملابس هربا من سيل الدماء المتدفق في
السودان خلال الايام الماضيه بالفعل كانت
علامات الرعب واضحه كانت علامات الارهاق
واضحه كانت علامات السعاده واضحه للوصول
اخيرا الى المنفذ المصري والانتقال فيما
يتعلق في المشهد داخل المعبر هناك ربما
عمل ايضا على قدم وسواق من كثير من
الاجهزه المصريه لاستقبال هؤلاء المتدفقين
من سواء من السودانيين او المصريين او
الجليات الاجنبيه هناك تسهيلات تسهيلات
طبيه يقوم بها الكثير من الاطباء
المتواجدين داخل هذا المرض من مركز ابن
بعبر مركز اغاثه وغيره ولكن هناك ايضا
عمليه تدقيق امني مشدده في موازاه هذه
التسهيلات خصوصا مع من يعتبرون اطفال او
كباري السن او من يبدو عليهم اي نوع من
الاصابه او الارهاق هناك ايضا تدقيق امني
فيما يتعلق بالقادمين تتذكرين بانه عقب
الاطاحه بحكم الاخوان عام 2013 كان هناك
رصد للكثير من العناصر الاخوانيه التي
حاولت الهروب من مصر في اتجاه السودان عبر
المعابر البريه ومن ثم هناك خشيه بانه قد
تكون هناك استغلال للفوض الجاريه هناك
ومساله عوده اللاجئين والتسلل مره اخرى
الى الاراضي المصريه وبالتالي هناك الكثير
التركيز حول هذه الامور ربما السياسيا
ايضا تتابع القاهره عبر منصاتها المختلفه
عمليه الوصول الى تسويه في السودان هناك
خشيه كبيره من ان استمرار الحرب قد يشهد
المزيد من التدفق من اللاجئين من المعروف
بان الاحصائيات الجاليه السودانيه في مصر
مبدئيا في حدود الاربعه ملايين نسمه هناك
خشيه من ان استمرار هذه الحرب واستمرار
عمليات الاجلاء خلال الفتره المقبله قد
تاتي ربما ملايين اخرى من السودانيين خلال
الفتره المقبله لا سيما له استمرت الحرب
وفشلت الهدنه وفشلت جهود التسويه سواء
الاقليميه او الدوليه طيب احمد يعني تحدثت
الى السودانيين الذين اتوا الى هذا المعبر
ولكن هل تحدثت معهم عما راوه او عاينوه او
عاشوه اثناء انتقالهم من الخرطوم الى هذا
المعمر هل من نقط تفتيش هل تعرضوا لاي
اذيه هل كان هناك تسهيلات ربما
نعم بعض تحدث البعض تحدث يعني لاكون صريح
بان كثيرون ربما رفضوا الحديث من هول ما
يعني من هول ما راوه يعني اعتذروا بنوع من
الادب بانه مرهقين يعني صعدوا الى
الحافلات بشكل سريع ولكن من تحدث منهم
يعني اتذكر بان احدا منهم قال بانها كانت
رحله مرهقه وطويله وان كان هناك ربما يعني
كان هناك استمرار للاشتباكات هناك من تحدث
بان كان هناك ايضا اعتداءات على بعض
الحافلات كل هذه الامور رصدناها من خلال
الكلمات المقتضبه لبعض من تحدثنا معهم
الرحله في وجهه نظر البعض هي حوالي 900 كم
من الخصوم الى هذا المعبر البعض تحدث بان
الرحله استمرت ما بين يوم ونصف ويومين
للوصول ربما لتجنب المرور في المناطق التي
فيها اشتباكات جديد بالذكر بان القاهره
تنسق مع يعني نظرائها في السودان لتقديم
ممرات امنه السفاره المصريه مستمره في
العمل في الخرطوبه القنصليه وايضا مكتب
العمل وادي حالفه اقرب نقطه داخل الحدود
السودانيه هناك الكثير من المصريين الذين
لقوا حتفهم هناك احد الشباب الذي توفى
وكانت قصته حديث على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وايضا خبر وفاه امس او مصر بشكل
خاص مساعد القنصل الاداري الذي توفى وهو
يحاول بان يقوم بجهود لنقل المصريين هناك
ايضا محاولات لنقل المصريين العالقين في
السودان عبر طائرات عسكريه تقوم بنقلهم من
الخرطوم الى القاهره بشكل مباشر كل هذه
الامور يتم مناقشتها من خلال خليه ازمه
وضعتها مصر والتي تضم عدد من الوزارات
والتي تقوم بالتنسيق سواء مع باقي العواصب
العربيه والدوليه فيما يتعلق بافق الحل
السياسي او ايضا فيما يتعلق بالوزراء في
السودان فيما يتعلق بتقديم ممرات انسانيه
وتقديم يد العون والتنسيق ربما للخروج
باقل قدر من الخسائر لهذه الازمه التي ترى
مصر فيها السودان ليس باعتباره دوله جاره
فقط ولكن باعتباره م لف امن قومي يجب ان
يتم التعامل معه بمنتهى الحذر والحساسيه
فيما يتعلق بمساله المشهد الدموي الجاري
هناك شكرا جزيلا لك احمد عثمان مراسل
العربيه كنت معنا من معبر ارقين على
الحدود المصريه السودانيه
مشاهدينا متابعه لملف الهدنه التي توسطت
فيها السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يبدو ان طرفي النزاع مصران على
مواصله القتال خوفا من تقدم الطرف على اخر
او استغلال فرصه الهدنه لاعاده الانتشار
لعبه الشطرنج هذه على رقعه السودان
الشاسعه لا تراعي بالضروره اوضاع
السودانيين الهاربين من النار والدمار
[موسيقى]
وفي سباق تبادل الاتهامات دانه وزاره
الخارجيه السودانيه استمرار نهج قوات
الدعم السريع باستهداف السفراء
والدبلوماسيين ومقر البعثات الدوليه حسب
وصفها وقالت الخارجيه السودانيه ان قوات
الدعم السريع اصبحت ميليشيا ارهابيه ضالعه
في ترويع المواطنين وقتل واستهداف
المدنيين كما حضرت من استغلال الدعم
السريع للهدنه في نشر قواتها وارتكاب مزيد
من الانتهاكات ضد المدنيين الخارجيه
السودانيه اكدت ايضا التزام الدوله
بالهدنه الانسانيه واكدت وقف القتال بعد
استجابه قياده الجيش للهدنه تاكيدا على
حرصها لحمايه المدنيين واحترام القانون
الدولي الانساني
قوات الدعم السريع كانت قد اتهمت في وقت
مبكر اليوم اتهمت قوات الجيش السوداني
باستهداف مواقعها قرب القصر الجمهوري في
الخرطوم ما يعد حسب ما ذكرته قوات الدعم
انتهاكا للهدنه المعلنه لاثنتين وسبعين
ساعه مؤكده ان القصف العشوائي للجيش يهدد
حياه المدنيين ورعاي الدول الاجنبيه في
الخرطوم قوات الدعم السريع اشارت مشاهدينا
في بيانها الى ان كسر شروط الهدنه المعلنه
يؤكد وجود اكثر من مركز قرار داخل قياده
القوات المسلحه
وبعد ساعات من سريان هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
بوساطه سعوديه امريكيه افاد مراسل العربيه
ان دوي او ذوي الاسلحه الثقيله عاد ليسمع
في اندرمان وفي محيط القصر بالخرطوم وذلك
بحسب شهود عيان فان هناك تحليق طيران وضرب
مدفعيه وسماع اصوات اشتباكات متقطعه
باسلحه خفيفه
هذا وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتن
بلنكن اعلن عن وقف لاطلاق النار بين
الطرفين بدا منتصف ليل الاثنين الى
الثلاثاء بتوقيت الخرطوم
وموضحا ان الهدنه ستسري في جميع انحاء
السودان
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع اعلن الموافقه على تنفيذ وقف
لاطلاق النار على مستوى البلاد يستمر لمده
الثنتين وسبعين ساعه بناء على وساطه
سعوديه امريكيه وذلك من اجل فتح ممرات
انسانيه وتسهيل حركه المواطنين والمقيمين
وتمكينهم من قضاء احتياجاتهم والوصول الى
المستشفيات والمناطق الامنه واجلاء
البعثات الدبلوماسيه
بجانبه دعا امين مجلس التعاون الخليجي
جاسم البديوي دعا طرفي النزاع في السودان
الى سرعه المضي قدما تجاه وقف العمليات
العسكريه والتحلي باقصى درجات ضبط النفس
وتجنب التصعيد وتغليل بمصلحه الشعب
السوداني وضمان امنه واستقراره بالاضافه
للحفاظ على مكتسباته ومقدراته والعوده الى
الاتفاق الاطري الهادف للوصول الى اعلان
سياسي
يضم الينا من القاهره الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني حمور زياد اهلا بك معنا السيد
حمور اذا تحدثنا قبل قليل مع مراسلنا على
الحدود المصريه السودانيه وذكر بان هناك
تسهيلات كبيره وكثيره من الجانب المصري
ولكن ايضا هناك تشديد امني خوفا من
استغلال بعض الجهات وبعض المنظمات
الارهابيه لهذه الازمه والعبور من السودان
الى الداخل المصري كيف يمكن التعامل مع
هذه المخاوف وهذه الازمه
هو طبعا حقيقي يعني في العام 2013
وماتلاها حدث نزوح كبير من عدد من كوادر
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وجامعات حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وغيرها من التيارات
المتطرفه الاسلاميه دخلت الى السودان
باعتبار ان النظام الحركه الاسلاميه نظام
عمر البشير في ذلك الوقت كان يشكل حاضنه
لهذه الجماعات لكن في تقدير ان يعني
علاقات القاهره وضغوطها على نظام البشير
سابقا ثم الوضع ما بعد الثوره السودانيه
اضافه الى الاحوال الاقتصاديه في السودان
خلال تلك السنوات
جعلت كثير من هذه الكوادر تفضل المغادره
والخروج الى دول اخرى في المنطقه او
الاقليم عموما
فلا اظن انه في خلال السنوات الاخيره ظلت
اسماء كبيره ومهمه مطلوبه للسلطات المصريه
موجوده في السودان لكن بالتاكيد يعني لا
يمكن ان نقول ان نسبه الخروج كانت بنسبه
مئه في المئه لكن الاعداد غالبا ستكون
صغيره في ظني ان محاوله التسلل مره اخرى
عائدين الى مصر قد تكون مخاطره اكبر يعني
ربما يختار التوجه شرقا او جنوبا هذا قد
يبدو منطقيا اكثر لكن في النهايه انا
اعتقد انه يمكن تمييز هؤلاء السلطات افترض
المصريه لديها معلومات كافيه عن من غادر
ومن خرج ومن هو ليس موجود في داخل الحدود
المصريه او في دول اخرى فيمكن بسهوله
اخراجهم يعني بتميزهم وسط القادمين خاصه
ان يعني استمعت الى شهادات من بعض
الواصلين انهم بقدر ما هناك تسهيلات لكن
يبدو ان هناك مراجعه مشدده امنيه على
وايضا لنا مراسلنا من الحدود المصريه
السودانيه ابقى معي السيد حمور لانتقل بك
الى الميناء الشمالي بمدينه بورتسودان شرق
السودان على ساحل البحر الاحمر لينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي اهلا بك
نزار انقل الصوره لنا لديك
الصوره كالتالي قبل نحو الساعه من الان
تحركت القطعه البحريه التي كانت قد وصلت
في الساعات الاولى من صباح هذا اليوم وعلى
متنها نحو ثلاثمائه من رعايه دوله الهند
في طريقهم الان الى ميناء جده ومنها
مباشره اما الى دوله الامارات في ميناء
دبي او عبر الخطوط الجويه الهنديه الى
نيودلهي وبعدها عبر المدن والمقاطعه
الهنديه المختلفه
مطار بورسودان ايضا مساء هذا اليوم
طائرتان ستصلان الى هذا المطار لنقل رعايه
عدد من الدول الاوروبيه والاسيويه في اطار
عمليه الاجلاء التي بدات في الحادي
والعشرين من هذا الشهر وما زالت مستمره من
خلف مباشره كما تتابعون الان عبر هذه
الصور الحصريه والمباشره هذه قطعه فرنسيه
قطعه بحريه فرنسيه وصلت قبل ساعه ونصف من
الان الى الميناء الشمالي ببرسودان وعلى
متنها
عسكري وعلامتها ايضا عدد من جنود على ما
يبدو جنود البحريه الفرنسيه هذه القطعه
التي يرفرف فيها الان علم فرنسا
وعلم عدد من الدول الاوروبيه والامم
المتحده هي ستقوم باجلاء عدد من موظفي
البعثات الدبلوماسيه وموظفي الامم المتحده
الذين يعملون في عدد من المنظمات الدوليه
الدوليه والامميه
العامله في السودان سواء كانوا في دارفور
او في اقليم النيل الازرق او في كردفان او
في عدد من المناطق هذه المرحله التي وصلت
اليها عمليه الاجلاء هي تاتي ضمن خطه او
وضعت لاجلاء الاف الرعايا الذين
قالوا بانهم يرغبون في مغادره السودان
جراء الاعمال التي حدثت الاعمال الامنيه
خلال الايام الماضيه مدينه بورسودان يغادر
منها بشكل يومي ما يقدر بنحو 600 الى 700
شخص يغادرون الاراضي السودانيه اما عبر
هذا الميناء او عبر المطار الجوي الذي هيا
ليكون احد المنافذ الجويه
لاخراج العالقين واخراج الرعايه بعد ان
اعلن السودان اغلاق المجال الجوي حتى
الثلاثين من هذا الشهر طيب نزار يعني
عمليات الاجلاء مستمره وعملي الطيران
مستمر والقطع البحريه ايضا تستمر في
الوصول واعداد كبيره من
المواطنين الاجانب يخرجون من السودان هل
منهم من يختار البقاء في السودان يعني
سمعنا تصريحات من بعض الدول بانهم يعني
يجلون او يجلونا من يرغبون بالتالي السؤال
هل هناك من يرغب في البقاء في السودان من
الاجانب رغم الاشتباكات والاوضاع الصعبه
هناك
يعني هذا السؤال كنت قد طرحته بنفس الصيغه
التي طرحت الان علي هل من يرغب هل هنالك
من يرغب هذا السؤال طرحته امس على احد
ابناء الجاليه الهنديه الذين ولدوا
وترعرعوا هنا في السودان سالته سؤالا
مباشرا هل ستغادر كما سيغادر المئات من
ابناء الجاليه الهنديه هنا في السودان قال
لي بصوره قطعيه انا ولدت في السودان ونشات
في السودان
وترعرعت في السودان وساموت باذن الله في
السودان اذا ما كتب الله لي هذا هذه الروح
موجوده لدى عدد كثير من ابناء الدول الذين
ولدوا في السودان وتربوا في السودان ونشوا
في السودان الخيارات التي طرحتها الحكومه
وطرحها الجيش وطرحتها البعثات لكل من يرغب
ان يغادر السودان بامكانه ان يغادر بعد
التنسيق مع البعثات ومع اللجنه التي يشرف
عليها الجيش هنا في البحر الاحمر او في
الخرطوم او في عدد من المنافذ البريه
والبحريه لكن هنالك عدد من ابناء الجاليات
وعدد من الرعايه قالوا بانهم يفضلون وانهم
سيراقبون الوضع من الداخل وان مصالحهم وان
اوضاعهم لا تستدعي مغادره السودان بما ان
الملايين من السودانيين ما زالوا داخل
السودان
فبالاحرى ان يكونوا جزءا من النسيج
المجتمعي الذي نشاوا وتربوا ورعرعوا
وترعرعوا فيه خلال السنوات الماضيه شكرا
جزيلا لك نزار مراسل العربيه كنت معنا من
مدينه بورسودان شرق السودان على ساحل
البحر الاحمر
فيما يتصل بعمليات الاجلاء اعلنت القوات
المسلحه الالمانيه اجلاء حوالي 100 شخص
اخر من السودان بمن فيهم مواطني المانيا
ودول اخرى ليصبح مجموع الاشخاص الذين تم
اجلائهم 500 شخص من السودان الى الاردن
عبر 5 رحلات منذ بدايه الازمه في السودان
واستمرار الاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع حسب ما افادت وكاله
الانباء الالمانيه
واعلن الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل اصابه جندي
فرنسي خلال عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
معلنا اجلاء اكثر من 530 شخصا من السودان
بينهم 290 فرنسيين حتى الان وتسع فرنسيين
جاء ذلك خلال تراس ماكرون اجتماع مجلس
الدفاع والامن الوطني حيث تمت مناقشه
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان
والحكومه البريطانيه بدورها اعلنت بدء
اجلاء رعاياها من السودان وذكرت الحكومه
ان طائرات عسكريه بريطانيه ستقلع من مطار
خارج الخرطوم تباعا ومن جانبه قال وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفري قال انه
لا يمكن اجلاء سوى حاملي جواز السفر
البريطاني وافراد اسرهم مضيفا ان الاولويه
ستكون للمرضى او العائلات التي لديها
اطفال او كبار سن
اعود الى القاهره وضيفي من هناك الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني حمور زياده سيد حمور ارحب
بك من جديد
يعني كنا نتحدث عن عمليات الاجلاء
والتجديدات الامنيه على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه ولكن سؤال التالي لك هو عن
الهدنه وعن محاولات اطلاق وقف اطلاق النار
ومحاولات الوصول الى تسويه سياسيه هل
برايك يمكن ان تنجح مصر الى جانب الدول
الاخرى في هذه المحاولات والمساعي الحديثه
للوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار
هو حسب ما اعلم ان هذه الهدنه المؤقته هي
واحده من يعني المحاولات التي تقوم بها
القوى السياسيه السودانيه بالتعاون مع
المجتمع الدولي
تاسيس مرحله فيها نوع من الهدوء لبدء
عمليه التفاوض ما بين
المتصارعين العسكريين مع بعض وجود ايضا
بعض السياسيين المدنيين
برعايه دوليه غالبا ستكون في واحده من
الدول الكبرى في المنطقه ستكون هذه
المفاوضات لن تكون داخل السودان حسب ما هو
متوقع
فاعتقد انه يعني تكرار اعلان الهدى هذا
خاص الهدنه الاخيره التي اعلنها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بنفسه لانها اتت نتيجه
خطه طرحتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بعد تفاهمات مع القوى المدنيه والدول في
الاقليم اعتقد انها قد تكون الخطوه
الاخيره قبل الانتقال الى هذه المفاوضات
هذا اذا نجحت الهدنه لكن يبدو حتى الان
انه كل واحد من الطرفين يحاول ان يستفيد
باكبر قدر ممكن من
اعلانه وقف اطلاق النار حتى يكسب نقاط
المجتمع الدولي بينما على الارض يحاول ان
يكسب مناطق اضافيه حتى يعزز موقفه في
التفاوض هذه المساله قد تعرقل عمليه
الانتقال الى التفاوض لكن في ذات الوقت
يعني
الاعلان عن بقاء سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
ورئيس بعثه ليونيتامس ممثل امين عام
المتحده الاعلان عن بقائهم في السودان
لمتابعه العمليه السياسيه هذا ايضا مؤشر
ان هناك حاله دفع امميه باتجاه التفاوض قد
تنجح اذا ما اقتنع الطرفين باهميه وقف
اطلاق النار الفوري اذا محاولات امميه
للوصول الى مفاوضات نامل بانها تنجح شكرا
لك من القاهره الكاتب الصحفي السوداني
حمور زياده
وفي خضم عمليه الاجلاء مشاهدينا ومنذ
اربعه ايام تلعب المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دورا انسانيا رائدا في اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من مناطق القتال في السودان
السعوديه خصصت قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده لاستقبال رعايه الدول قبل ترتيب
نقلهم الى بلدانهم في وقت لاحق
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اعلن وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان في تغريده على تويتر
اعلن ان السعوديه ستتواصل مع الاشقاء في
السودان لتامين ممرات امنه لاجلاء رعايه
الدول الصديقه والشقيقه كما اكد الامير
فيصل بن فرحان على مواصله المملكه لعمليه
اجلاء رعايه الدول التي تقدمت بطلب مساعده
مواطنيها ونقلهم لاماكن امنه
حاليا اول شيء هو الشكر الجزيل للقياده
والشعب السعودي على الجهود اللي بدلت في
سبيل اجلال رعايه الليبيين 104 شخص طبعا
طلقنا من يوم الخميس صباحا الى يوم الجمعه
رحله طويله لمده 25 ساعه الى مدينه
بورسودان وبعد ذلك بقينا ثلاثه ايام حتى
تمت عمليه الاجلاء
المملكه العربيه السعوديه على كل قدموا
لنا اياه طلعونا وجابونا وقعدونا الطريق
كنسل السومه وما قصروا معنا بشيء ما في
خدمه طلبناها ما كانوا موفرين اياها
فالحمد لله تم الاتفاق مع السفاره
اللبنانيه والسفيره اللبنانيه عملت
اتصالاتها مع السعوديه مشكورين كتير على
كل شيء قدمتوه من جهدك نحن بنشكركم كثير
من قلبنا
لابد انه نشير مشاهدينا الى هذه العواجل
التي وردتنا تباعا من الجيش السوداني حيث
قالوا بان مجموعات الدعم السريع نشرت
القناصه في مناطق متفرقه من الخرطوم
والولايات المجاوره واضافوا بانهم يحاولون
بان الدعم السريع يحاول استغلال الهدنه
لانقاذ موقفها العملياتي المتدهور بحسب
الجيش السوداني وايضا قالوا بانهم يحتفظون
بحقهم كاملا في التعامل مع خروقات الدعم
السريع للهدنه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات